Randy what would you say your top five
tips for dating are just the tip all
right guys famously single why do this
show i know for me i had a lot of trust
issues with men perfect as fast as you
can go I think that was probably it
still is but at least I recognize that a
little bit more now I cannot stop making
wrong decisions now have you guys heard
from your past co-stars about this show
have you heard from any housewives oh
yes oh really oh yeah a bad way they
just look they're like did you really
say vibrators and lingerie yes I do I
brought my vibrators in lingerie money
so they know I'm very I'm filtered and
they know me and they know that I say
whatever I want what I want I only
talked to cam and Yolanda but they're
both incredibly supportive and you know
they're doing they understand the
struggle we gonna see you back on the
show Never Say Never Never Say Never I
like it I like it so tell me about your
relationship with Eddie we were together
for 13 years I thought it was perfect
was it weird going through therapy on
camera yeah yes because you open up heat
of the world being said the world
doesn't know about you I think it
brought out like was like very wrong why
yeah it was intense I think we all kind
of the boys boys didn't cry they like
but it was like a fraternity on one side
and a sorority this guy's really shut on
is one Bishop with mines are you glad
you did it I am I really am I am I know
what I'm doing wrong and I'm working on
it so it's good
you